the number one way that people like date
now is from online dating and women only
swipe right five percent of the time so
if you go on a date with someone online
like he's he's the one getting all the
matches because you matched with him so
he's probably in the top five percent of
men dumb 10 20 and you know there's so
that means if I had like a lot of swipes
that means I'm pretty desirable yeah
yeah this is great I mean um you you
I'm sure you're in the top like what 10
of income how tall are you six full six
four so you're in the top um so only ten
percent of men are over six foot so I
don't I don't know what six four is but
that's so income you're probably top
five percent height you're probably top
five percent so yeah you could kill it
out here in the streets